[Musique]
comment s'est formé la lune en combien
de temps et est-ce une jumelle de la
Terre ou un astre à part entière ce sont
des questions que les astrophysiciens se
posent depuis longtemps
la nuit c'est fascinant de savoir qu'on
fait on sait pas vraiment comment elle
s'est formée même maintenant l'hypothèse
la plus courante la Terre aurait été
percutée il y a 4,5 milliards d'années
par Théa une protoplanète de la taille
de mars les débris de Théas se serait
ensuite aggloméré durant des dizaines
d'années pour prendre la forme qu'on
connaît de la lune aujourd'hui
maintenant on a une nouvelle hypothèse
qui nous dirait que peut-être en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que une collision
majeure très rapide avec une bonne angle
d'incidence qui a fait que cette
nouvelle notre satellite la Lune a été
formée très très rapidement cette
théorie d'une équipe de chercheurs
américains et britannique est basé sur
une simulation réalisée par un super
ordinateur elle suggère que la collision
entre les deux planètes l'angle
d'attaque la force gigantesque de
l'impact aurait pratiquement désintégré
teia et complètement remodeler la très
jeune planète Terre on a en effet
l'impression de voir des objets
mous début du système solaire et ce
qu'on voit par exemple la
protoplanétaire bien elle serait en
fusion comme c'est très très chaud mais
c'est essentiellement de la lave encore
plus surprenant l'assimilation montre
que la Lune se serait ensuite formée à
très grande vitesse en quelques heures à
peine à partir de matériel provenant
majoritairement de la terre
la composition de la Lune ne serait donc
pas faite à 30% de matériel terrestre
comme le sujet à l'hypothèse classique
mais plutôt à 60%, ce qui correspond aux
analyses des roches rapportées de la
Lune dans cette grande collision là la
lune se retrouve à avoir un cœur qui
appartient plutôt à la proto planète
Mars recouvert d'une enveloppe qui
ressemble beaucoup plus à la terre cette
lune toute jeune va ensuite continuer de
se transformer sous les nombresux
impacts de météorites qu'entraînent la
formation de notre système solaire
aujourd'hui elle est froide calme et
elle s'éloigne lentement de nous raison
de 3 cm par année éventuellement va
devenir de plus en plus loin jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit plus liée grâce
nationalement à notre planète Terre